the Brandenburg Gate is a triumphal arch
crowned by the quadriga
it's 20 meters high and flanked by two
gate houses
[Music]
Viktoria the roman goddess of victory
drives the chariots for horses millions
of people have seen the gate but very
few of them know how it came to be
a key event occurred in 1788 in Prussia
frederick william ii forged an alliance
with Britain and the Dutch Republic it
was very important to him and he wanted
to commemorate it properly so he built a
triumphal arch here anyone who wishes to
learn more about this monument can visit
the nearby Brandenburg Gate Museum
called the gate Berlin a multimedia show
reviews 300 years of history in 20
minutes it's aimed at today's young
tourists who are often pressed for time
on their travels
the journey through time in pictures
highlights for instance the roaring 20s
then Otto Hitler's Third Reich with Nazi
troops marching through the Brandenburg
Gate
[Music]
the 1953 people's uprising in East
Germany and its bloody suppression is
also commemorated the building of the
Berlin Wall in 1961 left the Brandenburg
Gate inside a restricted area between
East and West Berlin since the fall of
the wall in 1989 the gate has stood as a
symbol of Germany's reunification
from New Year's fireworks to the fan
zone for the soccer world cup today the
Brandenburg Gate is Germany's most
prominent venue for large-scale events
and the tourists they can't get enough
of the Brandenburg Gate
[Music]
just the magnificence of the building
how tall it is the carvings that are in
each individual pillar is quite
spectacular
I felt so tiny when you are in front of
this a massive building this is like my
first time to Europe and I've never been
able to experience anything such as
grand as this visitors can even take the
Brandenburg Gate home with them the
nearby souvenir shops offer a wide
variety of miniature versions of this
significant landmark in central Berlin